he needs a hold me back guy you know how
to hold me back guy you're in a fight
you're like Hey listen I'm gonna go out
to these guys I need you to hold me back
so I'm not I'm not actually trying to
fight this guy I need it to look like
I'm trying to fight this guy and I need
you to hold me back and it's got to be
off these guys weren't holding me I
would have kicked your ass he needs to
find a hold of me back I think elon's
told me that guy his homie bad guy is
going to be a hard sneeze he's one hard
sneeze away from getting like a back
spasm you know what I'm saying like
[Music]
laughs
all right we are live what's going on
dude amazing hoodie sick hoodie
you like that
Hampton yeah that is uh very nice I had
a team off-site we had all of our
employees get together in Brooklyn and
the CEO my CEO Jordan organized this
lovely event and he gave us all hoodies
that say Hampton and then our city
though we live in you're um you're a
stressful dude to organize an event for
I've never had to do it but I've been a
part of events where
um people are organizing for us and I'm
like they're like oh yeah um by the way
it's everything you know the venue
changed and we forgot you know there's
only one chair on stage I'm like it's
cool all right no problem and then
you're like what the hell and so I would
be very stressed if I had to throw a
offside or an event where you were
um my like kind of core customer of it
is that fair let me yeah yeah that's
fair but let me explain my reasoning
behind that and this is very business
related number one I believe the way you
do one little thing is the way you do
everything so what that means though is
once you have but but if you've proven
to me that I can trust you I'm all in
and I don't question anything and so
until you've proven that to me I
question everything and if there's not a
good answer behind it I doubt you and
once we get past that stage I'm good the
second reason
there is no second reason I actually
forget what it is a good reason
the second here's this here's the second
reason and we could actually talk about
this for a second if you want but
basically the second time around you've
done something everything is so much
calmer because now my entire reputation
my entire net worth it's not tied up
into this one entity which is what many
things I've done in the past have been
so I'm much calmer I'm way more uh
subdued uh this time yeah I think that's
true uh for sure and do you find
yourself thinking bigger as a kind of
like the way bigger no no this is uh
you've got one win under your belt
um what was the phrase that Justin Mayer
said once you do whatever you got to do
to get your nut and after that go for
your Noble Mission
um so you know you've gotten your nut
now you know you're you're financially
secure you're safe
do you not only are you calmer but are
you more I don't know ambitious or
long-term oriented in some way
yes 100 I used to criticize uh Founders
if they would sell secondary so you'd
read about this a lot you you typically
only read about it when it's done in a
bad way of which it's done in a bad way
many times you'll see this company which
is going to go bankrupt the founders
took 50 million dollars off the table
and it didn't work out the reasoning
behind that I think is great still uh
which is you give an entrepreneur five
or ten million dollars and they're like
wow I I can I can live a really nice
life now I think bigger that's
definitely the case with me I think
significantly longer terms so I think
like what's this like in 20 or 30 years
as opposed to next quarter and I don't
care if it fails which is actually a
good thing meaning I'm able to try more
within it I what if I said trade them
mean keep them Keen it's like that with
with trying to find a date and make
money so like you the less I care the
more it happens yeah I think the way I
think about it is like because you see
examples on both sides you see when
somebody had no other option Back
Against The Wall that's when they when
they when they Rose to the occasion and
you can also hear the other other
scenario which is because I was Secure I
was able to play a long-term game and I
was less emotionally
um invested in the ups and downs of it
therefore I was able to make better
decisions and blah blah blah you could
see both examples so which one is it and
actually I think the reality is that
Success is Not based on either one of
those it's not based on how much money
you had in your bank account when you
had zero or when you had a bunch people
tell themselves stories about it either
way I think fundamentally
if a person is driven
intrinsically driven
um it doesn't matter whether that fuel
is because
there are technologists and they just
love technology they're trying to make
something good for Humanity or they're
insecure because you know in seventh
grade uh Rachel dumped them and it's
like well either way it doesn't matter
uh you know like it doesn't matter what
your driving force is as long as you
have a driving force and it's different
for a whole bunch of people there's
there's examples of people on on all
kinds of
um you know uh like with all kinds of
you know chips on the shoulder I think
you do need to be driven and it's just a
question of by what and I think
everybody's got a different by what are
are you more calm
now that you've had success I'm
definitely more calm uh but I was pretty
calm before it's a common I would say is
not really the word I guess the way I
would put it is um
I'm less desperate
and like yeah yeah I think that has ups
and downs again like I said like
when I was desperate to prove myself
like
uh you saw that I worked in that really
fancy office I also slept in that office
I think basically it was like one year
was like 275 days out of the year I
slept there and like it was nice to
sleep there it's a really nice they had
an apartment built into the office so it
wasn't like the it's not like I was
sleeping under my desk on the like
concrete floor but nonetheless that just
sort of means you I just didn't have a
life I didn't want to have a life I
didn't want to care about friends and
dating and other things I cared about
just making it I just wanted to be
successful really badly and I was like
it's not even that I was super
productive all those hours but I was
like look I'm gonna throw all my hours
at the problem I will sleep here I will
wake up here that just seems more
efficient I'm just gonna do that I did
that for several years
but now I would say that desperation has
been replaced with
um you know a different asset okay I
lost the desperation which was serving
me what do I have now which is like I
can operate more out of a like I can
choose things that are like I'm actually
driven towards like to have a purpose
even if there's no more offensive as
well yeah there's no short-term path to
like right now for example I'm writing
this newsletter uh every day I write
this thing every day there's no ads
there's I subscribe no small boy or a
small boy yeah a small boy small boy and
I'm writing this thing there's no ads
there's no premium there's no upsell
there's no business model
so why am I doing it and I'm like
because I really like writing and more
than I like writing I like finding
interesting [__] to write about things
that you know scratch my curiosity so
I'm able to do something and then as I'm
doing this thing that has no business
plan that has no whatever I'm seeing all
these extra opportunities open up
because that I couldn't have seen at the
beginning and so just by doing the thing
I really kind of have drawn to I'm most
interested in I'm doing my best work and
when I'm doing my best work
these unforeseen things start to open
themselves up and I'm like oh I would
have the 24 year old me would have never
been able to do this because 24 year old
me was desperate and needed I needed a
payoff quick now I don't need a quick
payoff and so I'm able to do things
differently and I think that has a
different Advantage can we talk about
um
is there a new chip on your shoulder now
now that you and there's been a very
well you tell me is the feud that you're
experiencing right now your internet
Feud is that has that even made it to
the point where you bring it up at the
dinner table no no no but my wife is not
aware of it but she's like hmm how come
he's looking at his phone for like an
extra 30 seconds longer and it's because
I'm coming up with a a badass Slam in my
head is what's actually happening I'm
worth smithing a seventh grade insult
right now and uh I don't know what what
does my kid want what do you want hold
on Daddy's busy I'm coming up with a yo
mama joke to Jason calacanus right now
background of this is there's a podcast
called the all in pod they're great I
think they're good but they're different
than us and we uh we uh a lot of people
will listen to both of ours so maybe
there's a little definitely some
competition in there but we can all win
and last podcast Sean challenged them uh
basically to a hundred thousand dollar
poker bet uh heads up poker but there
was some more there's some more detail
behind it but I shared that uh on the
internet and Jason calcanus
I thought he was coming hard at me too
but he came harder he said Sam you're
great Sean you'll still learn and he
gave you a head Pat and he said uh smart
of you Sean to punch well I don't know
if he so the background is uh while we
were I forgot what we were talking about
I think we were making fun of him a
little bit because he um
in the Rogan debate people were like uh
you know it's raised two million dollars
for this uh the scientist to come debate
this guy like a kind of a a famous
internet challenge here and he's like
I'm in for 10K which is funny because
the answer for the record was doing was
100K Plus
I've never made fun of Jason if it comes
down to it I you have my loyalty I will
I'll die for you but I've so far if you
want me to I'll I'll I'm gladly hop in
I've stayed mostly neutral this is a you
thing yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
fine I by the way I like Jason for the
record I have nothing against Jason
calcanus uh I I'm uh I've listened to
this week of startups for a long time I
don't listen anymore but I used to
listen like back in the day I like the
all-in podcast uh it's sort of like two
thoughts that are both true
um
I like their content I have nothing
against them personally I've met him a
couple times uh in passing
uh you know whatever no no no no no uh
totally harmless there's no no no ill
will there also I think some things he
says are funny and cringy like funny you
kind of laugh at you not with you type
of thing and cringy like when uh the
thing I think the joke I had made that
he didn't like was that when um I said
all in his billionaires talk about
billionaire [__] MFM is millionaires
talk about millionaire [__] and somebody
goes actually it's more like three
billionaires and Jason kalakana and
their friend Jason callikanis and he
goes he came in for his own defense and
goes actually I'm a Sentai a centi
millionaire
I just thought that was cringe as [__]
which objectively and scientifically it
is and so I think he might have might
have taken offense to that and uh he did
he didn't fully like it but I would say
my poker challenge to them is only for
fun I just think it would be a fun thing
to do I think it'd be a fun thing to
watch
um I'm just looking for some action I
love playing poker they say they're
great at poker okay let's do a little
celebrity uh but no no celebrity
challenge nothing's been settled you're
not doing it yet well they didn't take
the bait I think yeah you know he was
sort of just like well you know you're
not famous enough for me to do this
challenge I have more to lose than I do
than I have to gain out of doing this
with sort of the the vibe I got which
honestly the problem with that is that
that's not entirely true are they are
they more popular you could argue that
for sure for sure but but there's a
ballpark and uh you know it's there I'm
in the stadium
yeah it's not like calling uh you know
what do I say it's not like kind of a
510 guy tiny you know what I mean like
you got to be at least five six to get
that nickname you're 510 here you know
what I mean not small enough yeah yeah
but the funny thing is as I was talking
about you know we should like on the
podcast I was joking I was like oh wait
is this fake Internet beef I would love
to have some fake Internet beef that's
you know this is how rappers for
Generations have been getting famous you
know they just have fake beef we should
do this as podcasters with other
podcasts and so I think that was the the
sort of like the the the the the the fun
behind it
we got one UPS big time just when I
thought me and Jason calcanus were
getting some some fake Internet beef
Palmer lucky comes off the top rope the
founder of oculus and Andrew comes off
the top rope it just body slams Jason
people love that and then while that's
going on
Elon Musk challenges Mark Zuckerberg to
a fight
and now
I don't even give a [__] about my own
poker match I need to see these guys
fight uh let's break this down we have
to do this story
Yeah so basically I don't actually don't
know how it started do you know how it
started but what I do I'll fill in when
Facebook actually Facebook officials
replied with a beautiful response well
there's a few steps to it so I think the
first thing was
um
I guess the old I think the origin of
this was a presentation leaked out of uh
Facebook that was talking about the
Facebook's coming out with a Twitter
competitor I think it's called project
92 or something like that and it's a
Twitter competitor
and their pitch was sort of like yeah
it's a Twitter competitor
um Instagram people will be able to
immediately have their Instagram
following on this so if you wanna if
you're already famous on Instagram you
can just start sharing short from text
like Twitter on our new thing and um you
know it will be run by like run in a
sane way like it'll be managed in a same
way I think was the something something
with the word saying in it and so
essentially implying that Twitter is
sort of insane and even the way elon's
running it is is uh Reckless
so that got out that that present
internal presentation leaked um maybe
intentionally maybe not I don't know and
um so Elon started making fun of of
Zuckerberg he sang like you know Zuck my
blank you know like you know he's just
sort of like you know tweeting stuff
like that and then somebody somebody was
like you know watch out zuck's been
training and he and Elon replies and
says
um I'll fight I'll fight Zuck in a cage
match
so he says this
and Zuck screenshots it
and post on his Instagram story with the
caption
send me location
which for those who don't know is a
iconic UFC slogan by khabib
uh one of the the great I think I think
one of the greatest uh UFC fighters of
all time
who was when he was fighting with Conor
McGregor and McGregor was like oh he's
scared he doesn't want to fight me blah
blah and Habib just goes brother I'm not
scared you want to fight me okay just
send me location just send me location
like basically where do I need to go
I'll fight you anywhere and so Zuck hits
Elon with the send me location
and this triggers a chain of events that
I thought was a joke so I thought
first of all I've never seen Zuck talk
trash that was already kind of an
amazing moment he he he he did a heel
turn which is awesome the second thing
is I was like okay well there's no no
way this is serious and then Elon sees
that tweet and goes or sees that story
and goes I'm serious I'll do it if he's
down
and then people are like wait what I
don't know if you saw this today Sam do
you see that Dana White's involved so
Dana White who's the president of the
UFC comes out because again I'm sort of
um you know my greatest fantasy would
come true if this uh if randomly two
Tech billionaire CEOs went and decided
to do a UFC match that's my two worlds
colliding
all of a sudden Dana White comes out and
he says I talked to Mark and Elon last
night both guys are absolutely dead
serious about this
um he goes this would be the biggest
fight of all time Floyd and Conor was
one of the biggest fights of all time
this I think triples it there is no
limit on how much this could make he
said it would be in Las Vegas it would
pay-per-view and it would be about 100
bucks pay-per-view
and you would have 51 year old Elon Musk
against I don't know like 39 year old
Mark Zuckerberg who's 100 pounds lighter
than him and uh
dude what is happening is this is this
real and then the Verge reached out to
Facebook in a Facebook official which is
a reply and they just said yeah and they
go the story speaks for itself which is
another like basically there's a guy in
the UFC that always says it is what it
is and that's exactly what what Facebook
just said they said we're it is what it
is it sounds it sounds serious and I
thought that was a pretty baller move I
think this is hilarious I think this is
awesome I love a freak Show a sign me
all right so I have I have some rapid
fire questions topic number one most
importantly do you believe this will
happen yes or no and why
um I believe Zuck will do it and I and I
and I think he would do it I think
there's not a chance that Elon would do
I think Elon would get very hurt just
training for it and I don't think
there's a there's a there's not a world
where Elon does so you think it's a no
uh no because Elon I yeah 100 agree with
you
I hope it happens I'm not saying it
won't happen but I would just if I had
to guess I had to guess I would say it
doesn't happen
because Elon realizes that he's gonna
lose a lot he's going to lose first of
all if he does that he's gonna get
destroyed he's gonna get tapped out and
if he if he does it
um I think he realizes that it's a
pretty bad look for him to lose to Zuck
his cool factor is really high and he
needs to find a a wiggle app he needs he
needs the uh he needs a hold me back guy
you ever had a hold me back guy you're
in a fight you're like Hey listen I'm
gonna go after these guys I need you to
hold me back so I'm not I'm not actually
trying to fight this guy I need it to
look like I'm trying to fight this guy
and I need you to hold me back and it's
got to be off these guys weren't holding
me I would have kicked your ass he needs
to find a hold of me back I think elon's
told me that guy his homie bad guy is
gonna be a hard sneeze he's one hard
sneeze away from getting like a back
spasm you know what I'm saying like he's
not the guy's not fit you know he he's a
he's a he's a charlie horse away from
pudding yes uh winner by noogie mark
um all right so so that's my second
question which is how do you think let's
say let's say our dreams do come true
this fight does happen
what do you think would actually happen
like predict the actual fight what would
happen fight starts what happens
I think that look so I I I I box for fun
and I Spar and what I've learned is it
doesn't really matter that much it
matters a bit but it doesn't matter how
in shape you are it doesn't really
matter how tough you are if you don't
practice that skill set and you go
against another person that doesn't have
that skill set it's just it's just your
light years away from one another just
being comfortable getting hit I think
Zuck would uh finish him within two
minutes he would probably uh get him on
the ground and Elon would tap from
getting uh his arm injured or something
like that yes
um now the counter argument would be but
Elon could train are you counting Elon
out this guy's proven he could do
anything he could train what's the
counter to that
he won't I don't think he'll train and I
don't think any amount of training look
you can't make a overweight 51 year old
fit in any amount of time the magic
powers of his epic he's already on his
epic he's already lost like 30 pounds on
his impact
it doesn't matter keep in mind zuck's
still only 39 I think or 38. no I I
don't think that Elon can train and I
don't any no amount of training to get
him here's somewhere here's some extra
data
uh people were on Twitter were like Elon
we love you but man I I think Zuck would
handle you here's what Elon said three
things that he said he oh I saw this one
he said I don't work out except for
sometimes when I pick my kids up and
throw them in the air so he doesn't work
out at all he doesn't exercise yeah
forget about fighting you guys
um secondly
he's like I'm so much bigger than the
guy uh you know just for reference
elon's like six three
200 plus pounds you know Zuck is
probably five nine I think five five
eight five nine maybe five ten Max and
uh is probably giving up easily 50
pounds in a in a fight here so weight
classes do matter anyone says I have
this move called The Walrus uh yeah I'm
just like a walrus I just lay on him
they can't do anything they're just
pinned this is this is no none of that
matters
Jiu-Jitsu people want to start on their
back with you on top of them
it doesn't matter I I'm not a
practitioner of Jiu Jitsu but I've
watched it enough that I feel I feel
confident at least in this call it is so
one-sided exactly it it doesn't matter
the way training like uh you could if
you're a beginner in Jiu Jitsu you can
go to a Jiu Jitsu gym for
six months
and you'll still be getting your ass
whooped by like you know people who are
just like you know one year ahead of you
because
the learning curve is very steep to
actually get good at this stuff like you
you don't pick up boxing or Jiu Jitsu
very quickly boxing I don't think would
be a factor I think the fight's going to
the ground uh both guys are too
uncoordinated nobody's knocking anyone
out both guys I think would look very
unathletic and would end in Zuck tapping
them out by the way do you see this
picture I put in the dock look at this
uh the picture of Elon wrestling a sumo
wrestler have you seen this ugh yeah
he said he's briefly done karate briefly
done Judo and uh and done a little bit
of Jiu Jitsu is what Elon has said in
the past if I had to bet on Elon versus
Mark on most everything I think I would
choose Mark Zuckerberg yeah like whether
business or fighting I think both
a good hang I think Zuck would be a
better hang I think Zuck it would Trump
him and just about everything don't you
agree on a good hang I think a lot of
people would pick Elon I think elon's
looser and more fun and it's like oh he
he smoked weed with Joe Rogan he must be
awesome right like this is like no I
think
I think he would be an awkward hang I
think it'd be very uncomfortable I don't
think I think Zuck is is just Zuck dude
they're both Podium on the in the
awkward Olympics I mean let's be real
yeah yeah but Zuck like you know he
reads books on where to place his hands
when he meets people like he's like
place on shoulder you know what I'm
saying like and he actually like studies
it you know I I think that
is going to win in every aspect do you
agree uh I agree I really hope this
happens there's this Dana White thing
gave me a slight hope but there's a
famous people don't know this Dana White
is a like
he's a world-class liar
um in fact if you ever go into like the
UFC communities on Reddit whatever like
one of the most famous like taglines of
the community is
don't believe his lies because he'll
tell you he'll sell you anything he's a
promoter
um he will he will try to drum up
interests
doing whatever he's got to do and uh and
and try to pull things off like that uh
this might be by the way this might be
the Hail Mary safe Twitter uh thing you
know like
uh Mayweather McGregor did like 500
million dollars if he thinks this is
going to do triple that let's let's just
pretend Dana White's not lying for a
second here if this fight did like a
billion dollars and Elon took home you
know 200 million dollars out of that net
hey that's you know just another few
months of runway for Twitter which is
currently uh you know unprofitable and
uh you know depending on who you believe
could be could be bleeding advertisers
I I have to imagine that there's also
like a life insurance policy that these
guys have like I wonder if it's like you
have to have security with you you can't
you can't ride a motorcycle dude they're
just gonna do what billionaires do
they're gonna just send in like a proxy
it's like here's my bodyguard versus
yours right like
history isn't this how like conquerors
fight they don't go fight themselves
they send in their best Gladiator
like the top engineer at Facebook at the
top engineer at Tesla need to go in and
fight for their own I would still I
would still bet on anything Zuck does do
you wanna um can we talk about beehive
yeah let's do it tell me a little bit
about the background on beehive all
right so what is beehive beehive is a
piece of software if you want to create
an email newsletter
beehive in my opinion is the best way to
do it I'm biased because I invested in
it but I also used it before I invested
in it we used it for the milk row we
built our whole business off this I
basically saw what you had done with the
hustle what the morning group guys have
done and you guys had all done almost
like what I'll call like The Homebrew
version of beehive which was like when I
asked you I said hey what should I use
for this you're like well you know
you're gonna here's some things you care
about you care about deliverability you
care about how easy it is for your
writers to write you care about a
referral program blah blah blah there's
five tools and what beehive was was and
it's complicated and it's complicated
and it's expensive and what beehive did
instead was the guy worked at morning
brew and he built out their like
referral and growth program I think
he left and he basically was like how do
I productize the internal Tech that we
kind of had at morning Brew so that it
makes it easier for anybody to create a
newsletter brand so and this is a
constant discussion that we had at the
hustle and my constant answer was no
let's just focus on this one thing and
that's true I made the right decision
because it's so challenging for a media
company to be a software company and
vice versa it's hard when you're doing
one thing to like I had ad sales people
I'm like you guys can't sell software
it's just different and he has proven
that I actually predicted I was like no
because we're not we need to focus and
also because I don't think there's a
market for it
so far I think I've been proven wrong
but I I haven't been proven wrong
totally so we'll see if she spins it out
here so he creates beehive it's
basically you go on you click a few
buttons you've got a newsletter you got
your templates you can create segments
you can do all the features of a
newsletter great
um
it's good we use it for the milk road we
build our whole business off this thing
we sell milk Road after a year or so
along the way
um I got pitched by him probably when
you did I was like hey I'm thinking
about this beehive thing uh we're
raising money big fans you guys would
love to have you involved and I I had
the same opinion as you I was like I
don't know it seems small it's like I
think I think there's some newsletter
brands that will be big but
um I don't know if they're underlying
Tech is going to be that big I don't
know if they're I don't know how big
that platform would be as a software so
we passed uh and I think the first
valuation we looked at was maybe
um yeah
you passed two at that time right for
same reason Market might be too small
and at the time I was saying no to most
stuff but really I also thought I I
don't think this can work I don't think
it's I don't think it could work at a
venture scale there's a classic lesson
here which is like um you sometimes
there's such a thing as knowing too much
um often the people who know the most
about an industry are uh either a too
much Scar Tissue they just don't want to
be involved with it anymore they just
want to go do other things they just
don't want to think about that because
there's too much like I spent seven
years I left a piece of my soul over
there and I don't really want to want to
worry about that again and the other is
you get too defined by like you know uh
how things are and you don't really see
you're almost too too deep in you don't
see where it's going this is why very
few breakthrough Innovations come from
traditional industry experts they come
from often beginners
um and why why would a beginner be able
to create a breakthrough not an expert
um because they come in with a fresh
fresh perspective and blank slate they
don't they're not limited by you know
the prevailing wisdom so that's that's
happened many times over
so we pass we start using it though I'm
like I'll be a user so you know that
there's that I'm not gonna invest but
I'll be a user so we start using it and
what did you think of the product and at
first it was good but I kept running
into these limitations and I would be
like hey uh oh my God they don't even
let you uh filter by X or wait you don't
even have analytics for my growth side
or the referral program only does this
you know like I would find these I'd
bump into the limitations because it was
very early on we were like one of their
first users I think and his reply I bet
was the best reply on Earth because
that's what it seems like it was the
perfect replies always which is uh I
hear you we agree already working on it
but let me see if I can get you
something a little sooner
um you know we're planning to release
this in two months but let me see what I
can do here and what they would do is
either he would manually do a workaround
for us and be like look uh we don't have
this analytics thing yet but here's what
I'm going to do I put a button on your
dashboard it's ugly it's gray nobody
else can see it it just but it's an
export it'll email you a CSV and then
can you just run the run the analytics
yourself for now until we build it so he
would give me a he would take three
hours and just make my life better
he would understand he would also ask me
a bunch of questions like so what are
you trying to really do here and let me
just confirm I understand this like a
good product person would do he's trying
to really understand the needs the
second thing he would do is then they
would actually ship the feature so he'd
say that's two weeks away I remember
telling Ben many times
then be like oh yeah they said they're
coming out in two weeks I was like dude
are you a rookie like no way start up
say anything they don't like no what
Engineers ever hit a timeline like this
never happens sure enough two weeks
later hey they proactively reach out hey
the features out test it out I want you
to uh I think it'll work for you guys
now and we would go do it and he just
did that three times so over the course
of about three or four months I was like
changed my mind call Tyler we need to
invest in this thing I was like but what
about your concerns about the market I
was like I don't know still might be
true but here's what I do know this
guy's an animal is making a product
that's really good and um you know what
this might be an example where the
market is bigger than you think uh which
has been the case for many Big Winners
like you know what's the market for you
know private black Town Car on demand or
crashing on someone's house as an Airbnb
right like these things can become a lot
bigger than you sort of initially look
at
if you sort of squint I've heard so many
people say the same thing about him and
I've noticed because I found him online
I've only talked to him once or twice
I've noticed online of him changing like
quickly moving quickly changing the
product quickly and whenever I saw that
I thought damn he's gonna do it he's
he's gonna I don't know how big but
something's gonna get pulled off here
that's that's like you could tell that
right away and this is uh so two things
on this one there's a framework that we
had at my very first startup we realized
this we were in the we were doing a
sushi restaurant in the restaurant
industry there's this weird phenomenon
which is
provide what's expected no points mess
up their order minus 10 points
but fix the mess up plus five points so
it's like I was like hold up if we had
just given him the right dish they don't
care they just move on as expected
if we mess up their order they're angry
but if we Fast Fix and we not just fix
their order but we give them the freebie
with it or we ex you know we we really
may come back and make sure that they're
all good or we take it off their bill
all of a sudden they had a tremendous
experience with us and they'll go tell
their friends and I was like what's with
that and I came up with this sort of
like the Fix-It theory of restaurants
which is actually mistakes
they're gonna happen anyways and
actually what you need to train instead
of a mistake minimization it's how fast
and how like thoroughly can you fix it
because that actually creates like a a
higher net promoter score that's
beautiful this guy's doing this with
software basically did you make this up
yeah I'm sure there's um some I'm sure
there's some name for this I don't know
this is like a whatever or you know
discovered very hard way but like I'm
sure there's a fancy name for that oh I
just called it the Fix-It Theory right
like if we fix it it's all about how you
fix it and the fix it's where you get
the like die hards so that's a very good
I noticed that and um so he was doing
that I'll give you one other little
beehive story which is like a little
dark maybe it doesn't want me to share
this but like do you know at some point
I'm bad am I right this the CTO passed
away right
his CTO passed away so we were having a
biggest jerk of all time he says the
two-week thing something didn't happen
in the two weeks one time and I was like
dude come on you said whatever where's
that feature we really need it don't you
understand how important my newsletter
bubble I'm being like you know I didn't
say those words but like I'm playing it
up in a way here we were we were just
like oh God complaining like it's not
ready yet he's like I'm so sorry we're
just dealing with something right now
his co-founder or CTO had passed away
during the startup and they were you
know that's a very hard thing for any
entrepreneur to deal with yeah he
handled that like as well as a human
being can handle it meaning was totally
you know like gracious and empathetic
around what was going on
but also understood that like you know
he's got it he he's got to keep moving
forward in some way and he's gonna have
to figure this out it's not an easy
thing to figure out I mean like
all kinds of great you just don't know
the passwords to half the things right
like he's like all kinds of stuff that
you don't even really think about
because knock on wood this never happens
but you know just seeing how somebody
overcomes adversity and deals with
really tough situations is another thing
where you sort of see you know
characters revealed in moments of
difficulty and adversity you see how
somebody handles something you think you
know what I think they're going to
figure things out fast forward to I
think it's really young too right he's
like 20 he's he's in his probably 27.
yeah something like that yeah he's he's
pretty baby face I don't know he seems
youngish
um I'll tell you two other interesting
things so yesterday the reason why we're
talking about it is yesterday they
announced we should probably should have
led with this yesterday they announced
they're raising uh they raised a series
a 12 12 and a half million dollar series
a from light speed like a 50 million
dollar valuation I think uh is what an
article said yeah I think a little more
than that so they they raised uh this
money
and it's uh and they he posted a graph
of their ARR so their annual recurring
revenue and it's uh hockey stick curve
it's three million in ARR and like I
don't know how long let me let me check
I think it's sort of like uh
um
yeah three million AR and like 12 to 8
like 18 months maybe something like that
um
just really really impressive and so he
uh the Run rates I think four million
he's like and he said in the thing we're
trying to end the year at 12 million and
uh super impressive and the end this
year so go go from four to twelve that's
what he's trying to jump he says
currently at a four million run rate
um they have three million of recurring
revenue from their subscription product
plus another million of revenue from
their like because they'll help you
let's say you want to sell ads or you
want to monetize your newsletter they'll
help you monetize your newsletter too so
they have like other products now
um wow and it says uh yeah I forgot you
posted the chart but I think it's like
roughly 18 months to two you know maybe
24 months at the Max uh that it did that
oh you got a call out in the in the
TechCrunch article it said used by milk
Road
hell yeah that's right I'm in the
ballpark baby
um so you know you know I think that
this is a good good uh an interesting
example I'm curious to see how this
plays out I could see this still
honestly going one of two ways you know
I'm an investor but I could totally see
this being a great business that wasn't
Venture scale meaning like he might sell
this thing for 100 they might get to 25
million in in revenue and sell for 200
million dollars I think that could be
that's probably the expected outcome to
be honest would that be would you be
happy with that yeah I'd be happy for
them yeah I mean we would make some
money it wouldn't be like the type of
return we would like you know that you
would like in a startup portfolio you're
obviously looking for these like Billion
Dollar Plus outcomes but hey you know
like that's a win's a win and I would be
really happy happy for their team so you
know I think that would be life-changing
money for him it'd be a great outcome I
think that's like
that's like the the the like if they do
well if they execute well I think that's
on the table I think what's the question
is how big does this kind of newsletter
media thing get can this get to the
scale where okay if they're if they're
trying to get to 10 million AR this year
they're at four trying to get to ten
if they get to a hundred right say 10x
once from if they 10x from there over
the next you know five years
that's now a billion dollar company the
question is like can it become that
um what would they need to do to do that
I think that's going to be the be the
challenge or the big question for them I
don't think that's gonna happen if I had
to bet I think that there's a nine
figure exit that's gonna happen here
that will make them wealthy it'll be a
huge success I don't think a billion
dollar company is going to happen
um I think it's too challenging I think
that um I'm an investor of convertkit if
you Google convertkit and then the word
bare metrics you can see all of the
revenue and the churn on convertkit
convertkit's been doing it for eight or
nine years I think and
you they're a little bit more focused on
small businesses as opposed to beehive
which is like Freelancers turned one-man
two-man companies and you can look at
their churn
of convertkit and I would think it's
better than beehive and it seems very
challenging to get to a hundred million
in Revenue in a venture times an
adventure time frame yeah I think that's
I think that could be uh totally totally
totally the case so on convertkit
they're mrr right now says basically
three million a month so 36 so it's 30
36 million a year 36. and look at the
churn I think it's four percent a month
yeah 3.5 percent a month
um so does that mean that most people
churn out after one year is that what
that math means no uh I don't know I
don't know I can't match into public
math definitely definitely don't try to
do monthly compounding into into
extrapolated that for 12 months that's
not easy for me
um
but I think through you know three and a
half percent churn per month is uh you
know obviously not great but uh it's
also not like bleeding in in SAS metrics
no not at all and I think that I would
rather be Nathan Barry and own 90 of
that company of course Nathan probably
had money or had some income coming in
so we had like the ability to do this
and like you said everyone's got to get
their nut and get it how you can yeah so
I think it's going to be massive success
I just don't know if it's going to be a
billion dollar company but I think that
the takeaway here for myself for you and
for the listener is the speed of
shipping new stuff and making iterations
and more so talking to your customer
constantly and hearing what they have to
say and asking them why not what do you
want but why and I'll come up with the
solution I think that's the takeaway
here I think the fix it menu thing is or
the fix it framework is really really
really good uh is that what you call it
I'll give it I'll give you two other
little Frameworks around this so one is
from Paul Graham Paul Graham wrote this
essay once where he goes um
thing I've noticed you know in
successful entrepreneurs program created
YC so he saw you know whatever thousand
plus everything they're trying to come
through there and picked picked very
well he goes one of the things I would
say is most commonly linked with like
success he goes can you describe this
person as an animal
and what that means is not oh he's like
a giraffe he's got a long neck no it
means could you just be like dude that
guy's an animal right dude she's an
animal uh it's basically just just just
describes the sort of tenacity intensity
and speed with which somebody moves and
just figures things out and gets through
obstacles and breaks through plateaus
and that one piece of like kind of like
investing advice
has really stuck with me and like served
me well because it's really easy to get
analytical about the market
about the product about the industry
about the competitors and uh you should
that's that's good look at it from all
angles
but whenever I'm like this person's an
animal
I'd make a bet for better or worse I'm
just like I'm just gonna err on the side
of betting on people when I think when I
can describe them as an animal uh
because
that type of person could figure things
out and I think on balance it's just a
higher predictor of like outside success
um and also the opposite is true I've
had I've made some mistakes in investing
when I'm like oh love this Market love
this product and I'm sort of projecting
if somebody was just a beast and took
this on they would just crush it
and I kind of overlooked the fact that
the person going after it is sort of
soft and timid and
seems to lack aggression and doesn't
seem to know their [__] I don't really
know their numbers that well when I ask
about their customers they don't post on
LinkedIn a lot yeah they keep wondering
about stuff and when I ask them what's
going on three weeks later they don't
really have Clarity on like what's
changed what's better what they're
focused on
um you know when they hit they get
overwhelmed easily
and it's like I've dude I've also talked
myself into Market uh you know Market
Investments and I I guess for me early
stage investing I think that that is the
person an animal is just a very
important test that's one
[Music]
where's the word
HubSpot is easy to adopt and actually
looks gorgeous I think I love our new
CRM our software is the best HubSpot
grow better
I got an update from a company I
invested in and they're talking about
their new like LinkedIn content series
and that was like the main thing and uh
and this is a software company and I was
like okay
but how about Revenue profit and like
how fast like you know what I mean I was
like I I don't care also I don't care
about the new hires frankly 100 I'm
gonna [__] on my own portfolio this way
I would I said this the other day I said
to my investment part of Romaine I go I
mean man like I feel like
maybe 15 best case 20 of our our
portfolio
writes good updates I said
that makes me worried because I was like
really there's two buckets there's
people who just don't write updates at
all or they're inconsistent and they pop
up when things are good or they need
something and they disappear for nine
months when things are going tough and
program also has written about that
which is
um when you stop talking is when things
go bad um like the people who survive
are the ones who continue being in
communication even when things are tough
and when you omit information when it's
like exactly hey so why didn't you just
put how you you told me how much your
burn was and your lot why don't you put
your cash balance in there exactly uh
like like you know I could do the math
we invest in one company early on that's
a pretty famous company in Silicon
Valley and it was really hot for a
period of time and now it's like people
have gone in tower on it I know what
you're talking about and they said uh
they like would write their first when
they were when it was really hot they
would write these very surface level
updates like
uh we hired this VP and this person and
this person and we brought on this new
investor it's like cool but what about
the business how's business going and
you're almost like it's almost like
don't ask about the business let's see
what's going on why is that the feeling
and then sure enough 18 months later
oh bad news coming out we had to do
layoffs and there's bad press article
and all this stuff and
we're just you know we need to raise
money but it's not looking good it's
like what's your burn rate oh we burn 3
million a month I was like dude what and
why haven't you been saying this right
like it's an unbelievable
and then and if you ask them like okay
what's the problem right now it's like
well the problem is you know the funding
market right now and this that's like no
the problem was you were burning three
million dollars a month for a long
period of time without the corresponding
like you know reward for that burn
um you know you weren't growing in
proportion of that burn and you were
Reckless with money right like that's
the reality that's the honest lesson out
of it you might be telling yourself some
other story
um similarly with our portfolio up to
about 20 of writing good updates and a
good update is
here's anatomy of a good update I might
actually just release a template for all
on this but it's basically
um hey guys as a reminder we are Hampton
what we do is this right like first just
like say what you do uh not that like
your investors forget but is in general
you're not top of mind for people and
you should have a real clear Punchy
thing that you're Drilling in this
Association whenever this whenever you
think of this word think of us whenever
somebody has this problem think of us
and so like first start with that then
say
last month was and your answer you're a
great month uh good or bad
answer that question and then write the
kpis and the kpis got to be
Revenue active users or active usage
active customers in some way
then the negative of that so some churn
or you know cost number associated with
that your net burn Maybe
cash balance you know how much cash do
we have on hand and then you want to
write the number for we have to write
the number for what it is in parentheses
you want to write
how much is that up month over month and
what is your goal right how are you
doing against your own goals because our
annual goal is to get to 10 million in
Revenue it gets 100 million in revenue
and to do that we need to be doing
accent we're actually either above that
below that or on track that's the honest
way to start an update below that you
can write whatever the hell you want to
be honest you got to write that part
first the next part you should write is
why that happened so revenue is down
because blank revenue is up because we
tried this affiliate thing and it's
actually working pretty good we're going
to double down on it revenue is down
because
blah blah blah users is flat because
you know we didn't do XYZ or we are
doing XYZ and it's just maintaining we
got to figure out how to get to the next
level so you have your your sort of two
sentence commentary on the metrics then
after that you could put your ask like
here's what I need from you and below
that you can put in whatever the hell
updates you want honestly I don't like
the fluffy the fluffy stuff yeah what
you don't want to do is what a lot of
people do
hey um we have this article can you
share that's the you know the start of
the update
um just a quick update on our end good
month for us
um we made these four hires I want to
welcome you know Steve it's like why are
we talking about Steve your VP of
marketing
um you know they just go on you know
Steve used to work at Visa but now he's
over here and that's really great uh
blah blah oh on the product side we
release these new updates it's like dude
this is not where you put patch notes
um like your investors care about
something and um you don't want to go
over here and wave your hands about all
this other [__] that's not actually like
the core relevant for information and I
think uh
it's just wild to me that people don't
get that I I refuse to like
I'll die on that Hill that's how
investor updates should be written and
it's crazy to me that people don't just
do that consistently
yeah when I see that I just think you're
lying about something this goes back to
what I said about the way you do one
thing is the way you do everything if
you're not honest if you're not honest
about it I think that you're lying about
other stuff and I just and and so I
think it's really important to do these
things really in the right way I used to
do this all the time at Dallas so I felt
I think you used to send me your updates
and they were phenomenal they were
perfect it was exactly in this format
and you were like you know you're just
the University of common sense it's not
like you were like getting mentorship or
advising or just your fifth startup it
was just like all right what are people
going to care about like obviously the
key metrics how I think how it's going
what I think about those key metrics and
what we're going to do next that's
basically what your update was I think
what I understood is that like people
basically want to get rich they want to
get laid and they want to have power
like most of my things in life are
rooted in like knowing those three
things
um and the problem with a lot of Silicon
Valley companies is they think that like
the answer of but I learned a lot is
good enough when it's like no man I give
you my hard-earned money I expect a
return and you need to be uh uh what are
they Scott belsey told me he goes you
need to be a steward of capital and I
heard that and I was like oh man you'd
make it sound so official I sound like a
knight like I'm just like deploying like
money I'm like I'm like a knight in
shining armor to do this and so there's
like that and it's basically like I'm a
small business owner trying to make
money and my business is investing in
your company you just took money out of
my family's mouths and you know boot off
our table that's how I feel and so if a
person isn't doing everything in their
effort to give me a return on my
investment I get [__] pissed if they
do really hard they work really hard and
they fail or if they make errors I'm
cool with that because I knew that I'm
playing the lottery here but if they do
this soft [__] and they don't aren't
honest about it it kills me kills me in
the sense of lying I actually think
that's the minority case and I don't
think people are actively lying I think
people if they're lying to anyone
they're lying to themselves I think what
I would actually it's lying through a
mission it's lying through a mission
it's what it is so so I think it's
there's three scenarios either
you know the situation and you don't
want to say it bad
or you just don't even know the
situation you're not on top of these
things really bad it's usually the first
or you know it
you don't want to say it
and you're intentionally withholding the
information in order to mislead or
misrepresent or whatever the worst and
so it's really bad bad or badder right
like you know the bad bad or bad it's
it's like there's really not a good
explanation the only good explanation
that I will accept
is that there are some companies that
are doing so phenomenally well and they
know that investors are actually kind of
a leaky a leaky bucket
and they don't want
they want to get a they want their Rumor
Mill to go ahead now let me tell you the
number of times it's that out of 100 is
one out of a hundred I had that happen
to me did I tell you have I told you
about this so
all right so the hustle was supposed to
sell the deal was supposed to close on
February let's say 5th February 5th was
the uh their earnings call was all
supposed to be supposed to be on
February 5th and that's a big deal for a
variety of reasons but there's like
legal implications here uh you know the
sec's involved so it could be it's as
simple as like if I told someone that we
were about to sell our deal wasn't big
enough to do this it did happen but it
wasn't because of us but where the stock
price can change significantly at the
announcement and if I told someone and
they make a big trade which has happened
multiple times not with us but multiple
times there's insider trading that's
against the law you go to jail
that's in you know so there's like that
implication there and there's also like
other implications around like you know
it's just not like cool it's it's not
like it makes you look bad well anyway
we're supposed to close on let's say
February 5th someone told axios on
February 4th I get an email from Sarah
Fisher I think her name is someone
leaked it to her I had only told I told
a small amount of people who were
helping me I think I told you who are
like guiding me and I also had to get
like some people to sign some paperwork
and I explicitly said don't tell anyone
this is a big deal I think I told them
this will ruin the deal if you tell
people which isn't true but you know I
told them that I could have and February
4th the day before we're supposed to
announce it I get this email from Sarah
and she goes I have uh a source saying
that you guys are selling and she told
me a bunch of facts about the deal that
I was like how on Earth do you know this
and it didn't back it leaked and I we're
not a big company like we're not we
weren't big enough that this is like I
don't I don't know why this should be
gossip but it happened and it freaked me
out big time and so I understand that
perspective of not telling people
certain things with my company now with
Hampton things are going well I'm not
going to talk about it too much when
things are going well shut up I think
that you should shut up yeah
yeah so I understand that perspective
but it happened to us and it it drove me
crazy and I was I I have I suspect it
was one of three people to this day I
hold a grudge with that again with all
three just as preventative measures just
preventative and I just stare at what
they do and I'm like I'm plotting I'm
plotting to find out Intel that they did
it and B I already have my revenge plan
and I'm just waiting and I check it I
check what I check up on them constantly
and those people probably know who they
are because they see me looking at their
LinkedIn all the time I want to like I
want them to know that I see them
they're like
I said you know it keeps he always keeps
tabs on me what a good guy oh I'm
looking I'm looking a lot and so I have
a feeling who uh who it was but can you
tell me about this uh Black Rifle story
because I have a little bit of
information about them too yeah this is
a kind of fun moment so we so a few
episodes ago we did this what's black
say what Black Rifle coffee is all right
Black Rifle coffee it's a coffee brand
so it's a coffee brand that I would
describe as like it's
like kind of patriotic it's like it's
like has an American vibe to it and um
the customers are mostly middle-ish
America or Southern and they uh they
they are probably right which is like a
Target it's kind of like a you know just
to put it in a box which I'm sure they
don't they don't love but like whatever
just to for for simplicity's sake
um started by veterans I think so it has
three or four like three of the four
guys or four of the five guys were
former you know military Marines
whatever some something like that and so
they and they're Hampton members by the
way ah there you go and so they
um so they they start this thing there's
a kind of interesting origin story to
this uh it becomes a it becomes a really
popular brand in fact like not only do
they sell a lot of coffee
um they sold enough they sell enough
product that they basically they've gone
public so uh let me see if they're
stocked as I think it's three or four
billion dollar market cap still it's a
little less uh now maybe the whole
Market's gone down so
Uh current market cap is 1.1 billion so
they build a billion dollar like uh a
DDC brand basically consumer consumer
packaging do you know do you know how
they started one of the owners had a
bunch of Facebook pages I think he had
like 30 Facebook pages ranging like I
was like [__] for moms to like veterans
and he started selling a ton of stuff he
was like look at all the stuff they were
selling and they were like damn we
should make our own thing and that's how
the coffee business I I believe that's
how it started so I did a call with him
one of the one of the guys which one um
Richard and so I think he might be in
Hampton too so he um
he had said something slightly different
he didn't talk about Facebook pages he
talked about YouTube so he was like I
was like what's your story he's like
well I was like you know he's like
wanted to be an actor who goes to
Hollywood it's like whatever it's not
really working out exactly great he's
been in a couple things but he teaches
himself to code he starts making iPhone
apps really early on in the iPhone app
store does pretty good with that ends up
getting hired by Verizon or something
like that to do like something on the
marketing side for them and um along the
way he starts doing YouTube fairly early
on and so he's doing YouTube videos and
um
for the brand but then also for himself
like personally doing YouTube videos and
he starts building a pretty big YouTube
following and then him and his buddies
start trying out different products and
they're trying out you know this and
that and oh should we do a I don't know
what the examples were but it's like you
know um let's just pretend t-shirt brand
and a shoe brand and let's do um
you know this this thing that thing hats
and then coffee was one of them and the
coffee one took off and that's kind of
like how they they rallied around Black
Rifle coffee to this day I think they do
like tens of millions in merch sales not
to coffee but just like people love the
brand so much they'll buy the t-shirts
and so tens of millions of merch that
there's T-Shirt Company there's fashion
companies that do tens of millions and
that's their whole business this is like
their their spin-off business that's
like how strong the the brand is in fact
when I'm on the zoom call with them his
background I'll I'll put a picture up on
the YouTube channel but it's just like a
great example of like this kind of like
the subtle branding that exists today
when you're on a zoom call it's like
your background your clothes like says
everything about you because that's how
we meet now right so you can actually
bring a full story in about your home
and everything and he's got like you
know on the wall he's got his his camo
thing he's got his gun he's got his like
he's got all the stuff that's kind of
like that same vibe that you know like
you know the American tough guy military
veteran uh you know like that sort of
vibe so we're talking he's telling me
this great story and um the reason why
we're talking is because he's like dude
I was listening to the Pod and I heard
you talk about the total man thing
he's like something just hit me he's
like I just love that I love the total
man thing I went on I saw that somebody
had the domain and uh I bought it um and
I was like oh cool like I didn't I was
like I swear I looked and the domain
wasn't available he goes no no I bought
it off somebody like I think he bought
it probably like 10 or 20 grand and he
was like yeah he's like I just want to
gift it to you and like if you want to
do something with it right like um
that'd be awesome
um that's a ball or something I hope I
can write this off or something but uh
you know I just wanted to do this I was
like a baller move uh it's like when
darmesh I think has done that for you
like on your birthday bought you you're
doing he bought me a um like a 20 000
domain it could have been more right but
it was copy that.com he bought it and so
uh baller move and just and I was like
what resonated about the total man thing
he's like I don't know man he's like I
just felt like
um the way you talked about like
the way you and Sam talked about just
like look it's important to me that I
like stand for something my own I live
by a code
um I care about Fitness I care about
these things
um like I care about being a man and
like that's important to me and like
you're right that Society has really
like pushed this thing that if you're
trying to be a man you're it's like
toxic masculinity
and it's like doesn't have to be like
you don't have to be a jerk or uh you
know like um rude in any way but like
why is it bad to like want to be manly
and I think it just kind of like
resonated with him and so we bought this
and we got a lot of [__] for that you
see people some people were angry about
that and that's right I think there was
an understandable reason that they were
angry which is we gave it and we when we
were talking about it we were like you
know I think you're seeing the craving
for this type of content and this
movement embodied in people who take an
extreme version of that like Andrew Tate
or uh stuff like that and people like
people just immediately they hate Andrew
Tate so much they got blinded by rage
and they're like you guys are saying
Andrew trade it's awesome and this total
man thing is about Andrew Tate it's like
no no I'm just saying like when you look
at objectively that this guy's extremely
popular he's the number one most Googled
man in America right now it's all under
an umbrella and we're saying what is the
appeal I think part of the appeal not
the whole thing but part of the appeal
is that this guy preaches that you need
to live like a like a [__] man and
he's like you know be hard don't be soft
like mentally be hard be tough uh
physically be hard be fit
um you know in your relations with
people don't you know be a softy don't
get pushed over don't keep apologizing
and groveling like you know carry
yourself like a man I was like I and I
was like you know what we had said was
that
I think the pendulum has swung too far
in One Direction where a lot of people
are preaching like a a um uh sort of
like I don't know what you would call it
almost like a soft or sort of like a
genderless like identity thing where
it's you know it's not cool to be a man
and I think that's building up a craving
for people to want to be a man and so I
don't know whatever something resonated
with that he bought the domain and I was
like oh yeah we should do something we
should try to just make it an open
source movement of and and when I mapped
it out I I did a little five minute
brainstorm the other day with Ben
and I was like yeah what is it what does
a total man mean I was like par this is
a good this is a good little branding
lesson I was like
I was at first I I went down the path of
like what matters to me like what
matters to me is like I like to have I
care about like Freedom like Financial
Freedom I care about Fitness I'm trying
to get more and more fit I want to be
somebody who is free to move their body
in certain ways and it is is a very fit
individual
um but I also care about family and
whatever and I was like
oh I think I just described something
generic I said what's the real appeal of
this total man thing it's not this well
well-rounded appeals to actually nobody
and I said Sam said something once on
the podcast that made me laugh
but I kind of like I wanted to make fun
of him and I also kind of liked that I
was like jealous and I wanted to make
fun of him at the same time what was it
you you said this thing it's gonna sound
so simple it's gonna sound dumb but you
said
it's important it's important to me to
be a [__] man
I was like what what are you what are
you even saying isn't that obviously
you said that and you go yeah it's just
important to me like to be a man and
like to be like you know I don't even
know how you explain it maybe you didn't
even explain it that was made the movie
was the beauty I don't I don't remember
exactly but I say it to Sarah all the
time I go I take care of business I go
we take care of our business you know
like all and that doesn't mean money
that means you know look I'm gonna
provide emotionally uh financially
spiritually I got you like we I take
care of business whatever you need I got
you I'm here for you yeah and uh it's
like I'm not gonna I'm gonna try my
hardest not to get too emotional if
you're emotional I'll be a rock I'll
treat you with respect I'm gonna take
care I'm gonna handle business that's
what we do exactly and I was like I
think it's more that it's basically I
was like I don't think it's about this
well-rounded blah blah because it
dilutes the message well here and I also
said and then I'll let you go I said um
when I like to exercise I want to be
able to outrun or what did I say I said
I want to either kill and eat everyone
in the room or outrun them I I saw that
from Galloway from Scott
don't you feel that way
and I was like hell no I feel that way
what are you talking about it's a
ridiculous thought you took your most
ridiculous thought and then said don't
you feel that way sometimes no I've
never once in my life looked around a
room of men and been like I could eat
and kill all these people or outrun them
not once but when you said it it's stuck
in my head it was provocative I wanted
to make fun of you but I was also like
you know there is a nugget of Truth in
this madness and that is where a real
brand is built and so that was my my
little branding Revelation to myself
when I was doing this exercise around
that what should we do with this total
man domain I was like honestly it's real
simple it's about being a man being it's
about men who want to be be a man what
does that mean we don't need to explain
it it's somebody who handles their
business you can come up with all the
examples you want
it's not a checklist that's not the
total man attitude is a having some some
predefined criteria checklist no in all
situations be a man about it and that's
when I was like let's take care take
care of business that's the brand Baby
Be A Man About It no matter what the
situation be a man about it and I was
like that's the total bad philosophy you
could apply that to whatever situation
you're going through in life but what
are you gonna do with it so is this
gonna be uh I know Jesse itzler who
we're gonna have on soon I've been
emailing with him he's got this really
cool thing where it's like you run up
this mountain a bunch of times and
that's like climbing Everest that's kind
of cool you I mean an event is the is
the obvious one but but you can go a
bunch of ways
here's here's here's the idea Fresh Off
The Dome you just said what do you want
to do with it you asked a great question
my brain came up with an answer
it's inspired by 75 hard which is also a
very totally exactly and it's great
join movements sometimes we create them
so we're gonna create our own version of
this and it's gonna be the man month and
what is the man month
it's basically 30 days where you commit
to to working towards being the total
man in these like you know couple ways
and it's like
for 30 days
we're doing cold shower
we're doing 50 push-ups right when we
wake up our 100 push-ups right when we
wake up first thing
it doesn't matter oh you're late
all right you're 10 minutes more late go
right oh you can't do 100 push-ups
I'm waiting keep going
we'll stay here till you're done uh
right so all right so push-ups and calls
push-ups and cold I think is two
we just need a third and it's gonna be
you do these three things you're just
gonna do them for 30 days straight and
we're just gonna Harden you up it's
gonna Harden you up a little bit
and so what's the third what's the third
in this thing well
is this too soft you gotta you gotta you
gotta tell you gotta tell the woman in
your life how you feel or the man or the
man in your life you got to be kind
you gotta tell someone how you feel it
could be kind it could be oh you've been
avoiding confrontation it's time to say
well you gotta have a tough conversation
oh you really appreciate somebody
you better show it right and so you're
gonna send a message voice memo text
message what to your mom to your
co-worker to whoever we can do that
every day you gotta have a tough combo
do that every day for 30 days
a tough conversation
a tough shower and a tough morning
that's how we're doing it
all right well you got to call it total
right a total conversation totally a
total one and so I think it's good I I
my feedback you need to add two more
things my critique of my own thing here
it's a little too easy
I think it needs to be a little bit
harder potentially it's got it has to be
so hard that you're like ugh I can't
believe I'm doing like the 75 hard thing
it's pretty hard and people have to look
at you and be like are you nuts yeah the
cold thing the cold things you're on to
something with the cold thing that is
quite challenging but you got to have
about you gotta have a few more hard
things 50 push-ups if you're fit I could
do 50 push-ups in one sitting yeah
the original thing I was thinking about
because I was like what would it mean
because a lot of this also inspired when
duck did the Murph thing and I was like
whoa sucks kind of
been a man right now like what's going
on this is that's pretty cool could I do
that I don't think I could do this I
can't do 100 pull-ups like this is
something I can't do right
all right so I started working towards
it so the next morning I woke up and I
did my little quarter Murph I I ran the
oh he runs a mile hard I'm gonna run the
quarter mile I'm gonna do a quarter of
the push-ups quarter of the pull-ups
quarter of the squad it's hard right
and I'll do it again until that's easy
when that's easy I'm gonna make it
harder all right I'm just gonna keep
inching it forward until I could do the
full thing and I was like yeah that's
the way to go it's progress right like
it's about progress and so I think
you're right I think we kind of need to
Workshop the actual uh difficulty level
because I think it to hit the brand
right it's got to be something that
other people think you're crazy for
doing yeah I I think that's great it
can't be reasonable you could also be a
little self-serving and make it like a
post on social media so you get that
little hashtag going around by the way
no you got to show me the results when I
charge money
this isn't a program you buy
it's just a movement you're either in or
you're out that's it that's it you're in
and if you're in you got to do it if
you're out yeah when so I've known you
for close to 10 years now did you ever
think that 10 years ago you'd be about
this life never
never
it feels good though right it feels good
to me man yes
it feels good it feels good look I think
it feels good I uh I I agree I think it
feels great I when I remember when I
moved to San Francisco uh San Francisco
uh people would make I felt really like
nervous I was like people would call me
a redneck because I moved from Tennessee
I remember when I when I first got uh
like in San Francisco when you moved
there you'd have to interview for an
apartment because they had so many
applications I remember going to like
one of these interviews and people being
like this was in
2012 right I guess right after Obama was
there an election in 2012 people were
like
who'd you vote for they asked me who I
voted for in order to like get this
apartment and uh like so I was like I
gotta hide like which I think we voted
for Obama but I had to like hide a bunch
of [__] about myself not anymore things
have changed my friend this stuff is
actually a lot more popular if you go to
San Francisco things are a lot different
muscles are are not quite in but they're
more in than before and fitness is more
than before and hard conversations are
more than before so I think it's good
that you're
kind of capitalizing on this we're not
taking some Trends here this is timeless
people have been trying to be people
have been trying to be hard for their
whole like you know since the beginning
of time uh you know in fact the only
thing that turns me off is if this is a
trend all right total man all right
you're you're sounding harder already do
you uh do you have to wrap up now I see
you're looking at your phone by the way
I'm gonna do with my Elizabeth Holmes
and start uh talking with a deeper voice
on purpose dude people make fun of me uh
on our YouTube they say I've got a high
voice yeah so so now I'm like thinking
in my head I gotta talk lower too dude I
think that's why Mike Tyson became Mike
Tyson I think he had to overcompensate
for his voice and just turn into an
absolute Savage oh so you're agreeing I
have a high-pitched voice
it's not low
oh my God that's ridiculous that is
ridiculous that is ridiculous
um all right that's the pot
[Music]
foreign